let's pull this next story this was
crazy this morning so uh New York Post
employee responsible for violent
reprehensible content on the website and
Twitter accounts this looked like a hack
at first no one say based no one say
based in a chat in reference to the
school one specifically the rest of them
were kind of freaky but there was one
post where they said to arrest the
teachers unions or something but here's
the story
uh this morning you know I'm preparing
my segment I usually record around nine
or so and then all of a sudden I see the
New York post Tweet out a call to to end
the life of a particular apology I'm
trying to be very careful because it's
crazy stuff and that apparently Ben
Shapiro wrote it and uh it was taken
down within a few minutes it was
archived a bunch of other posts popped
up where there were calls for death on
many other politicians and then one of
them that you're referring to Jack said
to arrest teachers unions and you were
like okay well you know Case by case
yeah I think there was but it turns out
to have been a rogue employees I think
there was not actually Christopher I
think there were some real stories mixed
in with some of the fake ones because
I'm reading this one and this one's the
headlines this one seems well this
headline seems real man shoved eight
inch deodorant can up his butt left it
in there for three weeks since a picture
of Adam kinzinger no no no no no that's
not a party the trick here is the
headline was real but that wasn't
actually Adam kinzinger ah the photo you
got you got you you could see you
right so a lot of memes started getting
made that
like I felt I thought that was actually
legit of Adam kinzinger but I guess I'm
wrong I I someone put his picture there
they put his picture there right but the
problem is now is that when you look at
some of the crazy news that's come out
just in the last 48 hours you're like
wait is this another hack or is this a
real one now yeah the Adam kitzerland
had me believed yeah but that one was
from a long time ago I think it was like
September or something the real story
but this is uh a rogue employee did this
and the question is why
why somebody were they Democrat I mean
to me honestly and I don't have any
inside info on this um but and I do know
people at the post but um uh I I think
this is probably just like a work
related thing
um seems to me like somebody was just
disgruntled at work had access but it
was overwhelmingly right wing targeting
the left
but and did you see hokel's campaign is
using it as legitimate yeah so let me
just stress this okay you're saying he's
a left-wing guy who did it I think or
it's politically motivated uh Kathy
hokel right am I getting her name wrong
yeah somebody had to know that it would
be their campaign pointed out that what
the New York Post said the vile violent
misogyny was wrong and they must answer
for it and it was like yo guy they said
they were hacked like nobody believed it
was real but here I said this this
morning when it happened there's going
to be evil Democrats who know it's BS
but know they can use it to lie to their
constituents and they're doing it 100
well that goes do what you're saying
earlier right that if someone only sees
this headline came up from the New York
Post and then here's governor hokel
who's someone that I trust and believe
because I'm a liberal Democrat and she's
saying that it was real and now I hear
some crazy Republican like Alex
bruzowitz or Jack pesobic well I'm not
going to believe did this dude get paid
because I'll tell you right now wow yeah
right now they can run an attack ad
saying in a shocking New York Post
headline Ben Shapiro called for right
and then because it's a fact it is a
fact according to the New York Post the
New York Post published this and so the
only thing Ben can do is Sue the New
York Post for damages because they're
the ones who said it that means every
single political action committee can
now use all of those headlines and say
in a shocking New York Post article
Republicans called for violence against
Joe Biden they'll say it and you can't
sue him now
congratulations
we'll see if it goes that far I mean if
it does I think it'll be called out
automatically I would call it out
is actually claiming it was it was real
and they're saying that your house do we
have our statements yeah the statement
came out really here we go look Jen
Goodman says the New York Post has long
fostered an ugly toxic conversation on
their front pages and social accounts
but these posts are more disgusting and
vile than usual the New York Post needs
to immediately explain how this
reprehensible content was made public
while the post has made its preferences
very clear in the New York governor's
race there is no room for this violent
sexist rhetoric in our politics we
demand answers this was pre-planned yeah
I'm sorry
that seems like that was look they know
that like you know we've talked about
Shapiro in Pennsylvania but you look at
New York Lee zeldin has been up in like
three of the last four polls that I've
seen in New York State uh hokel who was
a a candidate that an incumbent that
nobody actually voted for looks like
she's going to lose to Zelda and I think
she should by the way Zelda would be a
fantastic governor for New York um I
pray for the people of New York that
that they'll be able to be represented
by him in Albany but the idea that they
would have this statement already
pre-planned and the New York Post said
they were hacked 45 minutes before they
put it up
I mean this is crazy they knew what they
were doing because look at look at what
the implication is there the implication
is that these are the things that the
New York Post wishes it could write you
know because there's always that that
hit on on people that are conservatives
people on the right Etc well they'll say
well we know what you really mean we
know what that's a dog whistle yeah so
this is like America first as a dog yes
dog whistle right fascism globalist is a
slur right Global anti-semitic now they
say yeah so I just say internationalism
so is so is Alzheimer's Adolf I got
called anti-semitic for that one
recently but uh but I had some rabbis on
Twitter that came to my defense and they
said Alex is a great friend of the
Jewish people so I use Alzheimer's Adolf
still I just say internationalist
Nationalist and internationalist there
you go and then so I just say globalist
immediately because look at what they're
saying toxic conversation on their front
pages and social accounts more
disgusting and vile than usual but the
implication they're being that all of
the content of the New York Post is
disgusting and vile and again
what did we have exactly two years ago
was an article written by the New York
Post
that was censored resoundingly Alex you
just spoke about this
and it was Hunter Biden's laptop and
that was broken by the exact same
newspaper as the one that was targeted
today yeah that's a good point and they
were censored on big Tech social media
before sharing their stuff everywhere
that that according to many polls would
have changed the election yeah but that
story was was shunned the federal
intelligence agencies intervened and
told big Tech social media companies
this story could be connected to Russian
disinformation campaigns and if you know
what's good for you you're not gonna
post this story remember Mark Zuckerberg
said they visited him they visited Mark
Zuckerberg and told him yeah that
there's going to be Russian discount
information which specific specifically
to this story when the FBI knew for a
fact after interviewing Tony babalinski
that it wasn't of Russian disinformation
story they knew it was true they were
not verified it with Tony and they
already had the laptop yeah they
interviewed Hunter Biden's business
partner who came there and verified that
the laptop was real and they still went
around the big Tech social media company
saying don't run this just crazy they
went and arrested what was it 12
pro-lifers yeah because you're not
legally allowed to protest at abortion
clinics but when the protesters showed
up at the Supreme Court Justices Holmes
which is also illegal they did nothing
uh not just protesters showing up but
illegal at our uh Supreme Court Justice
Holmes Tim they had an actual antifa
psychopath who showed up outside of it
was Kavanaugh's house right yeah they
did arrest him with a gun they arrested
him after he turned himself in by
calling his sister and then calling
9-1-1 he was there with zip ties with a
backpack with duct tape
I believe he wanted to capture
potentially torture Kavanaugh and his
family his daughters and he said
specifically that this was because of
the Dobbs decision and because of his
second amendment positions he flew all
the way from California to do this which
very interested to how he purchased the
weapons Etc but when Alito came out
recently and said the Dobbs leak led to
assassination threats MSNBC and their
viewers were attacking him for saying
that because and this goes to your point
earlier they don't even know that this
happened they don't even know I disagree
there was assassination I think they are
evil people and they don't care I'm
talking about the followers yeah yeah uh
so again uh you know there's this this
tweet Aiden Paladin put out on Twitter
where she's like here's citation all
these studies showing that the leftism
is is dominated by Envy hatred violence
you know greed and I'm like just like
every Communists the history of
Communism yeah yeah it sounds about
right you know the problem is that
people keep thinking uh that they are
that that there is a left and that they
want to be on the left but they're
looking at a cult of violent extremists
thinking that represents true like
leftist values yeah and there's also a
lot of mental disorders and
radicalization that happens because of
big Tech social media censorship and the
echo Chambers it creates with its
algorithm and the man that you were just
describing I just looked up the story uh
he said that he was there to kill the
Supreme Court Justice to specifically
take him out yeah and to to ruin him
because of the disinformation because of
the propaganda because of the
psychological warfare that's happening
right now in our political system that
is literally pushing people to try to
assassinate other individuals because of
wrong think that's crazy exactly also
almost 200 days later we still don't
know who leaked from scotus yep and
there's no like is there even an ongoing
investigation it's almost like they
can't find the leaker and they can't
find the j6 uh you know uh pipe bomber
that guy still but they can track down
the 12 uh you know peaceful pro-life
protesters they can track down thousands
of Mega grandmas who showed up at the
Capitol on January if that was a
conservative we would have known in two
seconds it would be Behind Bars by now
absolutely I have good news though I got
good news guys let's pull up this story
from the daily wire
Schumer warns Biden on hot Mike that
Democrats are vulnerable in Key State
quote we're in danger that's a crazy
thing for someone to say like privately
we're in danger you're in danger why
because when the Republicans win there's
going to be inquiries maybe I really
don't think they'll do much but this is
the story they're basically talking
about Pennsylvania the seat that seat
we're in danger in that seat Schumer
told Biden adding a few months later
it's close we'll see so I they're
thinking that it's going to show you
seeing the breaking news on Elon and
Twitter yeah it's official it's not only
is it official but it says uh Elon just
17 minutes ago Elon has closed the deal
and fired the CEO and CFO
you know what we say to that hey
hey
goodbye thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there